social media had a lot of likes and some
really big dislikes to share we're gonna
talk about some of them in a segment
that we're calling viral overload
this past summer kevin and i covered the
olympics on peacock and some of our
clips went viral but shortly after the
olympics a new trend popped up on social
media
the hood olympics check this [ __ ] out
[Music]
one two three
four
do you know this was started by some
crackheads right of course this was a
this was a move that the crackheads told
the dope dealers if i do this you give
me a 20 rock
and then everybody around the world
started doing crackhead [ __ ] and didn't
even know it
[Music]
all to go viral yep just to be seen and
break your [ __ ] neck a bunch of
people [ __ ] up spines out there
because of this dumbass
next and spawns rearranged all over
uh that's a lot of fail videos but one
guy successfully took home the crate
gold check him out hey yo hey yo
everybody might say he's going up there
rolling up the port oh he's rolling up a
block
hold on if he pull this off he gonna get
it
he rolling up
looking like dj drama and drake and
[ __ ] uh
every light skin and they gotta know
oh he cold with it george is on point
look at his george
oh he licked it down
don't spin it and lip it
that's the spin lip technique right
there
you do that good on the roll when you
when you roll in the blunt that's the
technique that you use when you're on
the run like a lot of times when we run
in they're trying to get out of there
fast rolling up
[Music]
get out [ __ ]
get out [ __ ]
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] right here
is the standing [ __ ] off look
at this homie on the side and then it
was like the hype up from everybody else
is what makes it even better yeah
yeah
go get my light get that [ __ ] light
like that blizzy cause that was too easy
if you're an aspiring artist social
media is an amazing tool to help you
promote your talent roll a clip
and i've been trying to make oh my islam
boy
i imma just island boy i'ma just island
i'm speechless
two goofballs in the pool you know why
i'm not speechless why
because of my island
island boys
i'm an island boy
what is happening i don't know and ain't
trying to understand it damn it what's
understood don't need to be explained
and i don't know i don't understand it
doesn't need to be explained what
how i became my island
knock it off man
[Music]
you